but that wasn't what I was thinking
about that I see I was like okay here's
my story dude so I was super shy asian
girl right and this one
stupid [ __ ] Korean chick named Shelly
Kim I will take that back Shelly
I'll take that back I hate her to this
day no I don't hate her I don't hate her
it's like embedded in my brain so I was
a freshman right and I was so shy I've
never seen a penis I never liked
anything like it nothing like she was a
junior and her stupid little [ __ ]
boyfriend David he was a football player
and there were juniors and I didn't know
that he liked me and even know who these
people were
but then her and her friends somehow
managed to get a picture of me a real
quick [ __ ] all over it and then put it
in the hall hallway in the glass
what's important is she ended up telling
everyone that I sucked hella dick and I
see no the horrible [ __ ]
two days and I [ __ ] them all so then I
started walking around the halls where
guys are like what's up girl like I
heard you a freak meeting that shy I
like ran home all the time because I was
crying all the time
what a [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate her I really
did what does she have against you that
her stupid little boyfriend had a crush
on me that I didn't even know about
girls are [ __ ] crazy like I will say
that cuz girls too cuz they'll smile
they know talk [ __ ] about right yeah oh
yeah and the thing about is too that you
can't even sense it to hate you guess
what I say no sorry
so anyways going back I just went at one
point I got so so hurt and just kind of
crazy where this one tall as
[ __ ] named Daniel with big old
gums it was like hey freak I knew it was
the last of it and I was like ah yeah in
the hallway and I ran away this is not
the since then I just like been this
outspoken person he'll [ __ ] yeah like
I couldn't stand any more and you turn
the quiet sweet girl into the hood rat
hoshii yeah whatever happened to Shelly
kid oh no [ __ ]
what happened to you hope I got your
back I'm actually infuriated because I
don't like people like that
yes you a mrs. beale crazy are you
shopping here you [ __ ] [ __ ] ho
yeah the reason why you told everybody
she's sucking is probably cuz you suck
dick angry alright she's Korean
are you something else you ever come up
on my homegirl like that again I swear
to god I know [ __ ] other ghetto ass
[ __ ]
that'll [ __ ] slice she ass up in a
[ __ ] moment get a belly button dick
sucking [ __ ] IVA
[ __ ] whoa I don't either I really
that's crazy
she was so in C but how people always
say like about bullies but when you're
inside with yourself you put you push
that [ __ ] on to other people and that's
so true because she was afraid that you
were to take her men don't even know
them exactly but that's the thing though
that's how insecure she was oh man I
really hope she turned out to be a
hooker well it was her and your friend
they're crazy
so friendly Vicki or something like that
Victoria Victoria what park they're both
night and wait Victoria Park for
Victoria chain mmm
Victoria kid mm no she was a Chinese
Victoria Wong but you know what's crazy
we call you just know they're both Asian
Oh Victoria I think here's me to be a
man [ __ ] you mother [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you had to come here to tell my
[ __ ] career let them connect [ __ ] you
break you in half man talk about a [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] refugee [ __ ] you know
how easy it is to rap I told you all you
have to do is run words with words where
is it
word like telling you you can straight
up is because you overthink pretty much
you just gotta free your mind free your
mind rate yo man
they don't feel none of this [ __ ] makes
sense strong sympathy on Don and the
thing Don be my on the him in my she
game so we're gonna do a scenario I want
you to rap about that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Shelly Kim is her name's Shelly yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] Dessie there we go
scenario I shall I give you a [ __ ] we
went high school and I was nice girl I
never seen a dick and you said I did
you made me cry your [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] Shelley she mad at me
cuz my body tight that she got a big
belly gettin [ __ ] too much by that
football team
I asked her what you do for a living she
got [ __ ] I ain't got dreams she
stay at home she don't do [ __ ] she can
stay at home hating on other people see
you're that [ __ ] from the outside
staying at my door looking through the
peephole I heard you like to suck balls
too
I heard you got AIDS oh [ __ ]
rat battlers dude they got [ __ ] crazy
ass lines like rat bells are so [ __ ]
good they fightin they say information
about you that even you didn't know like
yo listen yo listen did you know that
you were adopted
oh you were born in Zimbabwe oh no what
what is good you give me a topic I'll
freestyle about it right now
cheers 400 girls what my name is Dora
the explora I'll be wearing purple and
pink don't even come my way homie all
this I be gettin steak all day you
should already know I'm a Mexican
you're a wack ass [ __ ] you ain't
never gonna have sex again Dora the
explora I explore my [ __ ]
options so when you step up to me no the
[ __ ] yellow tape on homie caution
I'll give you a [ __ ] uppercut
you ain't [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
I got a [ __ ] Mexican bow cut
you get so aggressive cuz you have to
kiss rock battle that's the only rapping
freestyle I know it's rap battle
so here when I do about a love song it
always turns about killing somebody oh
my god baby I was gonna propose to you
the other day cuz your face was so
beautiful I was looking at you I was
like I realize his life is full of [ __ ]
cuz you stand up to me [ __ ] yeah
yeah so do that get get [ __ ] angry
with it s watch how easy it comes out
okay give me a subject Donald MacDonald
McDonald's in Korea we say make the no
dude and it's so good you bout to get
fried up [ __ ] like a Chicken
McNugget [ __ ] this [ __ ]
you ain't stepping up to me you a
Chicken McNugget confidence be really
loud get angry and just rhyme with
whatever you [ __ ] want oh so hard
yeah den are you doing Danielle your
turn no this is gonna know you don't get
on the bars watch fits get on the bar
seven kids oh you looking slim hey
that's time my raps is alright but yours
has got to be fired when I hit the gas
what's rotating is my tires bars hi
sandwich lack of barberry got beef with
you homie I'm vegetarian [ __ ]
well I'm behind can I be take it too
hard
ah I say grasshopper jerk jerk
cricket that's even hard for me too
that's us that make it difficult for me
are you do it ah by so girls me to cook
some steak or food ooh good bars